cómo afecta esta vinculación con el
Partido Nacional Socialista Alemán la
imagen del candidato sabemos que en
múltiples ocasiones asegurado que
aborrece a los nazis y previamente había
dicho que su padre fue forzado a
participar en las fuerzas armadas
alemanas
yo creo que este no es un tema que tenga
de real importancia en los electores
chilenos quizás otra en su postura han
sido más controversiales quizás los
diputados las expresiones extrema contra
las mujeres eso sí ha sido tema te lo
han influenciado y de hecho en el caso
del programa te echó para atrás en la
eliminación del Ministerio de la Mujer
12 yo veo esos temas más relevantes en
la campaña de Jose Jose Antonio Kast al
menos en lo que hemos visto hasta ahora
bueno tanto como su familia han tenido
las dos importantes con la dictadura o
tuvieron las importantes con la
dictadura de Augusto Pinochet cómo se
justifica que haya un apoyo tan
importante a este candidato cuando
justamente el país está redactando una
nueva Constitución para eliminar la
heredada de ese régimen
es una muy buena pregunta y
probablemente tiene mucho que ver como
que eres se posicionó como un candidato
derecha y pico del gobierno de Sebastián
Piñera
interpretando un sector muy importante
de la derecha chilena y de alguna manera
adiós que el presidente actual no
gobernó con los temas propios de la
centro-derecha y por lo tanto ven en
casa alguien que pueda volver a la
derecha en su lo que era antiguamente
esa no tanto ligado al tema de noche
pero como un voto protesta la derecha
que trato de construcción Piñera
opciones reales tiene de llegar a la
presidencia y que le espera a Chile si
logra ocupar la Casa de la Moneda
pregunta al menos las 50 hasta ahora 10
días elección Dangan con ventaja a
Gabriel Bori y por lo tanto es le ha ido
remontando pero le queda todavía un
trecho por recorrer y la gran pregunta
que se hacen muchos nosotros incluido
cuál es el efecto el impacto que va a
tener esto en algo que tú me suenas al
principio al encinar que sigue se
encuentra este momento redactando una
nueva Constitución donde el ácido quién
crítico de ella y de hecho dijo que
había votado por el recta